legal eagle is coming in loud and clear
thanks to ting immobile lying to the FBI
is a federal crime now imagine this
scenario you have lied to the FBI
everyone knows that you lied because you
admitted to lying twice in open court
you said yes your honor I lied to the
FBI you sign a detailed statement
admitting to the facts that you
misrepresented you agreed to never file
a motion to withdraw your guilty plea
you signed a document allowing
incriminating things you said in court
to be used against you in future
proceedings and now it's time for you to
be sentenced and ultimately to go to
jail and the prosecution the lawyers who
charged you with a crime file a motion
in court saying in essence hold on here
we no longer think we can prove beyond a
reasonable doubt that this defendant
lied to the FBI so Your Honor we'd like
to dismiss these charges now in a
situation like this despite the
prosecutors change of heart the judge
has the final say over all of this and
since you agreed that you committed the
crime and that your statements could be
used against you you perjured yourself
to federal agents after all you admitted
to it twice so you're going to jail
right well if we're talking about you
dear legal eagle I'm sorry to say yes
you are probably going to jail but if
you are friend of the President Michael
Flynn
maybe not welcome to the latest episode
of as the Department of Justice turns
Oh past Devon you thought you're gonna
be able to release this video on Monday
I laugh you handsome idiot you have no
idea of the crazy stuff that's gonna
happen throughout the rest of this week
it's got everything from corruption of
the DOJ to whistleblowers at the FBI
crazy procedural stuff so if at the end
of this video it looks like I have bags
under my eyes and I haven't gotten any
sleep it's because I have bags under my
eyes and I haven't gotten any sleep
because I've continually tried to revise
this video to be up to speed with all
the crazy stuff that's happening it's
definitely worth your time this is
unprecedented in terms of what the DOJ
is doing what the judge is doing in
response to that so yeah let's stick
around it's definitely worth your time
it's an insane story and let's turn it
back over to past Devon you beautiful
[ __ ] if you're wondering what just
happened to Michael Flynn and why the
Department of Justice is attempting to
drop the prosecution against him and if
they can even do that I'm about to take
a deep dive into the ironclad case
against Flynn and the ins and outs of 18
USC Section 1001 and the big mess at the
Department of Justice let's start with
some background on Michael Flynn and how
he found himself in this particular
situation Michael Flynn was only
employed by the Trump administration for
24 days but a lot happened during those
24 days Flynn made many phone calls to
foreign governments particularly to
Russia and then lied to the FBI and
particularly the Trump administration
about those phone calls this happened
during a period when Flynn was already
being investigated for working with the
Russians so just who is Lieutenant
General Michael Flynn anyway well before
joining the Trump administration Michael
Flynn was a retired lieutenant general
who held two intelligence posts with the
federal government Flynn was the
director of the Defense Intelligence
Agency under President Obama and served
as the national security adviser to
President Trump while serving in the
Obama administration Flynn became the
first American to visit the GRU in
Moscow the GRU is the successor to the
KGB Flynn retired from the DIA in 2015 a
year earlier than expected and the
scuttlebutt is that Flynn's resignation
was generally attributed to being not
great boss but Flynn's stints in the
intelligence world were marred by
allegations of mishandling of sensitive
information and potentially deception
when
government official serves in a position
where they handle sensitive information
they are required to disclose all
contacts with foreign nationals and
governments during Flint's time as dia
chief his activities raised alarms among
some CIA and British intelligence
officers they claimed that Flynn
concealed his relationship with a
Russian British graduate students
svetlana likova whom flynn met on a trip
to cambridge in february of 2014 the two
carried on an email correspondence with
Flynn referring to himself as general
Misha now there's no proof that likova
was a spy or a honey trap for Flynn and
in fact she later filed a defamation
lawsuit against the Wall Street Journal
The New York Times The Washington Post
and MSNBC amongst others and this will
be of interest to all of you legal
eagles who watch my videos about
defamation because her lawyer was none
other than Stephen Biss the same lawyer
who represents Devin Nunez in many of
his what I think almost everyone agrees
are frivolous defamation lawsuits
against internet cows and other phantom
menaces now likova is case was dismissed
it was actually handled by a friend of
mine and I think this generally falls
into what you would consider an anti
slap suit but one of the questions that
tangentially I would like to have
answered is who is paying for Steven
BIST to file all of these crazy
defamation lawsuits if you happen to
know the answer to that question please
send me an email because I was very much
like to know
at any rate after Flynn's retirement
from the armed services and from the
intelligence community he started a
consulting business called the Flynn
Intel group and in 2016 Flynn appeared
at a conference whose participants
discussed the coup attempt against
Turkish dictator reset Berta WAN and at
the time Flynn was on record for getting
rid of erdowan who he believed was
pushing Turkey away from secularism and
toward radical Islam you may recall it
Erwin was the one that a few years ago
had his armed guards beat the crap out
of a bunch of protesters here in DC but
as so often happens
Turkish business groups hired Flynn
Intel group and paid them lots of money
such that by 2016 Flynn was lobbying on
Iran's behalf and on Election Day in
2016 Flynn wrote an op-ed for the hill
explaining of the u.s. needed to fully
support air21 and this was a
particularly big deal because Flynn was
the
former head of the DIA and was close to
the incoming president but there was one
big problem Flynn had failed to disclose
that he had been paid by turkey for the
consulting work when he wrote the op-ed
and the hill amended the article saying
that Flynn didn't tell them that his
firm had received payments from a
company with close ties to the Turkish
government nor did he tell them that the
company had reviewed the draft of the
op-ed before it was submitted and on top
of that as a retired military
intelligence officer Flynn is required
to obtain prior permission from the
Defense Department in the State
Department before receiving any money
from foreign governments however after
Flynn retired he accepted $45,000 from
Russia today in english-language media
outlet that is owned by the Russian
government
Russia today paid Flynn to attend a
dinner in Moscow where he hung out with
none other than Vladimir Putin and the
green parties at home Jill Stein now
Flynn also accepted money from Kremlin
linked companies for speaking
engagements but again he didn't seek
approval for any of this and this is
where fara comes in for the first time
after it was clear that Flynn was deeply
involved in promoting her to ones
interest this caught the attention of a
pentagon and other intelligence services
around the world it was clear that
Flynn's secret work for foreign
governments may have violated the
foreign agents Registration Act or Farah
Farah is a law that requires individuals
who are representing political interests
of foreign powers disclose their
relationship with the foreign government
and the information related to
activities and finances in other words
if you're working for foreign
governments the American public has a
right to know about it this is obviously
particularly important where there are
major policy differences between
countries and in this particular case
for the last five years the United
States and Turkey have disagreed over
whether the US should extradite Vitaly
Gulen a Muslim cleric living in the
mountains of eastern Pennsylvania
Gulen who's 81 is the leader of a
religious movement within Sunni Islam
called hizmet some say promote peace and
civility whereas Iran believes that
Gulen is a terrorist who is behind
efforts to remove him from power now at
the same time a Turkish national named
Bijan Rafiki in' was a partner in the
flynn intel group Rafiki and flynn and
others lobby the US government to
extradite Gulen to Turkey and as it
happens Rafiq Ian's and a co-conspirator
were later convicted in their role in
plotting to covertly influence United
States politicians and public opinion
against Gulen
and as if this wasn't enough Flynn and
his son were allegedly offered fifteen
million dollars to travel to the Poconos
and kidnap Gulen and extradite him to
Turkey and reminder why this is
important Flynn was frequently lobbying
foreign governments without disclosing
his activities or his pay arrangements
and it was around the same time that
despite this activity or perhaps because
of it Donald Trump tapped Michael Flynn
to be his national security adviser now
because of this on August 16 2016 the
FBI opened up an investigation to find
out whether Flynn was being controlled
or influenced by Russia he was being
investigated for violating 18 USC 9/5 1
which makes it illegal to be a foreign
agent this investigation wound down by
January 4th 2017 right before Donald
Trump took office the FBI was preparing
to close this case however during the
same period the Obama administration was
trying to understand why Russia had not
responded to the additional sanctions
that they had levied against Russia for
hacking US elections what they learned
is that Flynn had actually been chatting
with Russian ambassador kis lyac now
there are some circumstances where you
might want to talk to a foreign
colleague for various reasons in a
transition situation but what the FBI
found is that Flynn had been discussing
the sanctions that had been levied
against Russia by the Obama
administration and there there are
disputes about whether this conversation
was about policy or not but the context
of this conversation was that if Russia
indeed reacts against the Obama
sanctions then effectively the Trump
administration is going to have to
respond once it takes office so the
Trump administration didn't want to be
in a hole against Russian have to
retaliate against it
which under any reasonable
interpretation is a conversation about
policy now the case agent in charge
argued that the Flint investigation
should remain open because of this
particular information
now while the DOJ and the FBI tried to
figure out what to do
vice president Mike Pence suddenly and
publicly said that in fact Flynn did not
interfere with the Russians and did not
have policy discussions about the
sanctions allegedly that's because Flynn
lied to Mike Pence now query whether
Mike Pence knew about
information or not but the party line is
that Flynn lied to pence pence went
public with the lie and by proxy carried
that misrepresentation forward to the
American public I knew that he lied to
me and and I know the president made the
right decision with regard to him and at
that point the FBI decided to interview
Flynn about whether he was working with
the Russians or not the interview wasn't
about election interference per se but
it was in connection with the ongoing
concern about Flynn's own actions and
eventually Flynn agreed to have a
voluntary conversation with the FBI so
in this context let's talk about the
crime of lying to the federal government
under 18 USC 1001 it should surprise no
one that it is a crime to lie to the
federal government section 1001 makes it
a crime to knowingly and willfully make
any materially false fictitious or
fraudulent statement or representation
in any matter within the jurisdiction of
the executive legislative or judicial
branch of the United States now to prove
a violation of section 1001 the
prosecutor must prove the following five
elements number one a statement or
representation or document was made or
used to it was false fictitious or
fraudulent three it was material four it
was made or used knowingly and willfully
and five it was related to an action
within the authority of the relevant
federal agency now the third element
that a statement was material is often
the most disputed issue in a section
1001 case now according to the DOJ zone
handbook the test for materiality under
Section 1001 is not whether a false
statement actually influenced a
government employee or function but
whether it had the capacity to influence
them the ultimate issue according to the
DOJ is that if a lie is an attempt to
influence a decision-maker ie
convince them of something then its
material it doesn't matter if the FBI
already knows that you're lying or isn't
convinced by your line that doesn't
affect the materiality of the lie itself
in other words it's not necessary to
show that the particular lie ever really
influenced anyone and when the DOJ
prosecuted Flynn they argued and the
judge found that his lies were in fact
material so let's talk about the things
that Michael Flynn actually lied about
in order to
plead guilty Flynn had to agree to a
detailed statement of the offense now
this document is not always a
take-it-or-leave-it proposition from the
prosecutors and in most cases and
certainly in this case the defendant and
lawyers pore over the language and
negotiate with the prosecutors about
precisely what the defendant is
admitting to so what did Flynn admit to
lying about well there are three
categories of lies first lies regarding
his communications with a Russian
ambassador to the United States second
lies about his communications with
Russia and other countries about Israel
and third lies about his paid work for
foreign governments so let's talk about
the first category of lies lies about
Russia the special council led by Robert
Muller was investigating Russia's role
in twenty sixteen election interference
now a key issue was whether the Trump
campaign through intermediaries
including Michael Cohen and Michael
Flynn family members like Jared Kushner
and Don jr. and campaign staff like Paul
Manafort discussed the possibility of
lifting US sanctions on Russia in
exchange for help in the 2016 election
after President Trump was elected but
before he was sworn in the US government
implemented additional sanctions on
Russia Muller reported that people close
to Trump indeed tried to undermine US
sanctions before Trump was inaugurated
now according to Flynn's statement of
the offense On January 24th 2017 Flynn
voluntarily agreed to an interview with
FBI agents he wasn't coerced into having
this interview he voluntarily agreed to
talk with FBI agents now during this
interview Flynn said that he did not ask
Russia's ambassador to refrain from
responding to the new obama sanctions
against russia and he also said that he
quote did not remember a follow-up
conversation where the russian
ambassador said that russia had chosen
to moderate its response because
specifically of its communications with
with flint now those statements were
unequivocally false Flynn admitted that
on the same day that President Obama had
signed an executive order imposing
sanctions against Russia for its
interference in the 2016 presidential
election the Russian ambassador called
Flynn and when Flynn said he didn't
remember the conversation that was a lie
and there were additional phone calls
between Flynn the Trump transition team
in Kiss lyac Flynn admitted that after
he phoned Trump's people at mar-a-lago
he then called ambassador kis lyac to
ask that Russia not escalate the
situation and all
respond to the US sanctions in a
reciprocal manner Flynn then reported
back to the group hunkered down at
mar-a-lago Flynn spoke with kiss slack
again on December 31st when they
discussed Russia's intention not to
retaliate in response to US sanctions
because of Flynn's request and once
again Flynn called senior members of the
presidential transition team to tell
them that Russia wasn't going to
retaliate now why does all of this
matter why are these lies material
because Flynn was communicating with
Russia a foreign adversary that they
didn't need to retaliate against
President Obama's sanctions leading to
an inference that he was telling them
the president Trump would get rid of the
sanctions as soon as he was in a
position to do so it's also a signal
that President Trump didn't care that
Russia according to intelligence
agencies in the US interfered in the
u.s. election and perhaps most
importantly and most shockingly the
Russians of course knew at all times
what had and had not been discussed with
Michael Flynn and they knew what policy
might and might not be on the table they
knew what potential policy changes were
going to happen with the Trump
administration and worst of all they had
caught Michael Flynn in a lie they knew
that Michael Flynn had lied to vice
president Mike Pence and to the American
people so they now had leverage against
the national security adviser to the
United States they knew that he had lied
to the American people that's really bad
apart from all of the legal issues in
section 1001 or fara
that's basically a worst-case scenario
from a counterintelligence perspective
on top of that there were lies about a
UN resolution Michael Flynn admitted to
making false statements about a UN
Security Council resolution condemning
Israeli settlements Flynn claimed that
he did not request that any of the
countries take any particular action on
the resolution but in his statement of
the offence Flynn acknowledged that this
statement was false he really did
contact the countries to try and
influence their vote in the UN and then
there's the third category of lies lies
about paid work for foreign governments
when Michael Flynn took the job with
President Trump he made false statements
about what V Flynn Intel group had been
up to specifically his activities quote
for the principal benefit of the
Republic of Turkey Flynn made quote
materially false statements and omission
end quote including hiding that the
government of Turkey was directing his
activities although Muller did not
formally charge Flynn with violating
fara he did include admissions in the
statement of offense and Flynn has pled
guilty to those offences so that takes
us to Flynn's guilty plea so why did
Flynn plead guilty well as with most
criminals it's because cooperation gets
you a lighter sentence and sometimes
being charged with only a small fraction
of the offenses that ultimately could
have come down the pike and Flynn
decided to cooperate fully with a
special counsels investigation he
participated in 19 interviews with the
special counsels office and the
extensive cooperation convinced Robert
Muller to recommend relatively light
sentence and back in December 2017 Flynn
appeared in court to enter his guilty
plea he did not object to the
prosecutors description of his lies to
the FBI and Flynn admitted that he had
violated the law the judge asked are you
entering this plea of guilty because you
were guilty and for no other reason to
which Flynn replied yes your honor
he reaffirmed his plea at another
hearing on December 18th 2018 one year
after his first appearance and he said
that he was satisfied with his lawyers
representations did not want a second
opinion about pleading guilty and did
not want to withdraw his plea in light
of certain FBI agents being investigated
for misconduct and that he knew lying to
the FBI was a federal crime as part of
that plea Flynn agreed not to file a
motion to withdraw his guilty plea and
although generally Federal Rule of
Evidence 410 prohibits the use of guilty
plea statements to incriminate a
defendant in later proceedings Flynn
explicitly waived rule 4:10 in his
guilty plea but by January of 2020 Flynn
had new lawyers he had attempted to
withdraw his plea and claim that all of
his earlier admissions were actually
lies and was asserting that he in fact
never lied to the FBI no that's not to
say that Flynn's prosecution has been
completely without issue Flynn has long
complained that he was being railroaded
by the deep state and he had long
complained that his lawyers had a
conflict of interest and provided
ineffective counsel and that had largely
been an issue in terms of trying to undo
his guilty plea he obviously had pleaded
guilty several times and was trying to
be able to withdraw that plea now
through most of this ordeal Flynn was
represented by a firm called Covington
and Burling a huge US firm white-shoe
well known for being politically
connected and one of the biggest and
most well respected firms in the country
Flynn dropped Covington and Burling for
the after mentioned reasons last year
and signed with another very well-known
attorney named Sidney Powell
interestingly in April of 2020 of this
year Covington and Burling revealed that
they had recently uncovered emails and
handwritten notes that they claimed were
inadvertently left out of a trove of
records that they turned over to Flynn's
new lawyer Sidney Powell now it's hard
to opine on the claims of
ineffectiveness of counsel without
knowing more about the representation
here ineffectiveness of counsel is
generally a defense that applies to the
indigent not a political appointee with
one of the biggest firms in the country
that said it's pretty unusual to have to
turn over documents long after you have
been fired by a client and have that
client retain another lawyer I mean it's
not a good look to have potentially
relevant documents that the new attorney
needs to review and to see that being
said Covington and Burling had these
documents throughout their
representation of Flynn so it's a very
hard burden to show that failing to turn
over these documents to the new lawyer
is going to have prejudice to the prior
representation he's got a very steep
uphill climb to make there which takes
us to the actions of the Department of
Justice under the guidance of attorney
general bill Barr now with Flynn about
to be sentenced there was speculation
the president Trump would actually
pardon him for his crimes but it appears
that instead bill Barr took action first
in January 2020 Barr appointed a US
attorney Jeffrey Jensen to review
Flynn's prosecution this was unusual
especially since Flynn was about to be
sentenced and Jensen had never reviewed
any of the prosecutions that came from
the special counsels investigation and
query why we have a special counsel at
all if the actions of a special counsel
can simply be reviewed and undone by
later attorneys general you can see that
there might be a problem if you fire the
Attorney General and then appoint an
attorney general who's just going to
undo these supposedly independent
investigations of the special counsels
office we'll talk about that later
by the time that
Jennsen was brought on to review the
case the judge already ruled there was
no reason to dismiss the case but in a
brand-new motion the DOJ now claims that
it was totally inappropriate for the FBI
to question Flynn in the first place and
they're trying to dismiss the claims
against him despite his multiple guilty
pleas and being on the eve of sentencing
and to sum that up Flynn was
investigated for being a Russian agent
he had secretly talked to Russia about
undermining US sanctions he had lied to
mike pence about his involvement in
whether that's legal or not it was the
reason the Donald Trump gave for firing
Flynn in the first place or at least
leading to Flynn's resignation and he
had a long history of hiding his
involvement with foreign governments yet
unbelievably the DOJ is now saying that
none of that was a good enough reason
for the FBI to interview Flynn and that
those representations were not material
to that investigation and recall that
the special counsels office had a dual
mandate they were both to investigate
the counterintelligence issues at hand
and also any criminal liability that
might attach to the the Russian hacking
and interfering with the US government
now the only attorney to sign the do J's
motion to dismiss was newly appointed US
attorney Timothy Shea he's the head of
the US Attorney's Office in the District
of Columbia and thus he is one of the
top three most powerful prosecutors in
the country the other two being the
Southern District of New York and
arguably the Eastern District of
Virginia potentially the US Attorney's
Office for the District of DC is the
most powerful office depends on who you
ask
and it's important to note that Shea who
is a longtime colleague of Bill Barr
replaces outgoing US attorney Jesse Lew
who left the post at the US Attorney's
Office for DC to take up an appointed
position with the Treasury Department
but just a few months ago the Trump
administration inexplicably just removed
her nomination entirely so she was
effectively
fired from her her past job and the
Department of Justice through Timothy
Shea is arguing in this motion to
dismiss that the government had already
decided not to charge Flynn under Farah
so the decision to interview him by the
FBI was illegitimate now the DOJ had not
officially written a memo closing the
file but Shea portrays the closure of
the investigate
as a mere formality he went even further
by exonerating Flynn entirely stating
that his chats with kisi Lac were
totally fine and the do J's brand new
position is that quote there was no
factual basis for the predication of a
new counterintelligence investigation
nor was there a justification or need to
interview mr. Flynn as to his own
personal recollections of what had been
said the DOJ motion relies heavily on an
interview with former DOJ lawyer Mary
McCord this 2017 interview with McCord
about the circumstances of the Flynn
investigation was cited more than 25
times in the motion however Mary McCord
wrote an editorial just a few days ago
slamming her former employer the DOJ for
twisting her own words
now although Mary McCord is no longer
with the Department of Justice she was
an incredibly high-ranking official at
the time of the Flynn investigation she
was in fact the Deputy Attorney General
in charge of national security
according to McCord her interview merely
describes a quote difference of opinion
about what to do with the information
that Flynn apparently had lied to
incoming vice president Mike Pence and
whether Flynn's lies should be shared
with president-elect Trump not as to
whether the investigation should proceed
in the first place McCord states that
the debate was a completely different
topic that had nothing to do with the
legitimacy of interviewing Flynn quote
the report of my interview is no support
for mr. Bars dismissal of the Flynn case
it does not suggest that the FBI had no
counterintelligence reason for
investigating mr. Flynn it does not
suggest that the FBI's interview of mr.
Flynn which led to the false statements
charge was unlawful or unjustified
McCord said that Flynn's lies were
material to a counterintelligence threat
because his lies exposed him to the
threat of blackmail and McCord implies
that the do J's new arguments are
misleading because they ignore that the
investigation was into whether Flynn had
violated 18 USC 1951 in other words
whether he was actually working with
Russia or not the official investigation
was not closed because the FBI learned
about Flynn's conversations with kis
lyac and sought more information I'm not
an FBI agent but it doesn't seem
unreasonable for the FBI to hold off on
closing the file in order to question
someone who might
be spying for a foreign country and DOJ
prosecutors originally told the court
that Flynn's lies were material and that
any attempt to undermine the sanctions
could be evidence of collusion between
Russia and the Trump campaign whether
that ultimately proved to be true or not
doesn't mean that you can just get away
with lying to the FBI with impunity
again it doesn't matter if the FBI
believed what you were saying at the
time in ordered for the lies to be
material but in the motion that was
filed last week the the DOJ reversed
itself and ignored the judges prior
ruling in order to claim that things
have simply changed
the DOJ hasn't really told the court
what that change is just changing its
position and Tim Shea also argued that
the case should be dropped since the
government can't prove Flynn lied beyond
a reasonable doubt
this is particularly peculiar given the
number of times that Flynn has already
pled guilty to the matter itself there's
really no question that he lied it's
only a question of whether that was
material or not
now Shay's motion also claims that it's
based on new information but McCord
confirms that the DOJ had access to all
this information the whole time and
speaking of which one of the
high-ranking FBI agents has also come
forward claiming that the Barlet DOJ
interviewed him about his actions and
notes surrounding the Flynn interview
and failed to apprise the court of his
testimony and evidence which he claims
was counter to the do J's narrative in
the shade motion to dismiss apparently
in preparation for this motion to
dismiss the DOJ interviewed bill priest
F who was the former head of FBI
counterintelligence two days before
making their extraordinary request to
drop the case in front of Judge Sullivan
now apparently they didn't tell judge
Sullivan about mr. priest apps interview
and that's a bad look because generally
lawyers have a duty to present negative
evidence or negative authority to a
judge you don't have to give it the
light most favorable a stick knowledge
that it exists in the New York Times
reports that the DOJ is claiming that
they're in the process of writing up a
report of the priests type interview and
will in fact file that with the court
we'll see if that that happens now
priest F apparently says that the FBI
was never trying to lay a perjury trap
and claims that FBI officials were
trying to do the right thing in
questioning mr. Flynn and knew of no
effort to set him up media reports to
the contrary meanwhile not everyone at
Department of Justice is just sitting
idly by Brandon Vondrak who heads a unit
responsible for prosecuting violations
of Farah withdrew from the case and from
to others where Flynn is a party this
tends to be what happens when a lawyer
does not stand behind the pleading that
his boss wants him to file we saw that
in the Roger stone sentencing case where
four US attorneys withdrew from the case
because of what appeared to be improper
interference by AG bar and although the
Attorney General is a political
appointee the DOJ is overall law
enforcement goals shouldn't be partisan
the vast majority of people who work at
the FBI in the DOJ will spend their
careers working for both Republican and
Democratic administrations this doesn't
mean that they aren't entitled to
political opinions but their opinions
aren't germane to their investigations
and it shouldn't interfere whether they
decide to prosecute someone or not or
give special treatment to other people
in government and in fact former DOJ
lawyer Jonathan Kravitz wrote in an
editorial for The Washington Post
revealing that he left the DOJ because
of similar match nations involving the
Roger stone investigation Kravis was
especially offended by bars earlier
comments criticizing prosecutors for
their actions and as crabbers points out
career prosecutors and FBI agents aren't
allowed to comment publicly about
criminal investigations nor can they
respond to their boss AG bar Kravis
wrote Department lawyers are ethically
bound to protect the confidences of
their client the US government bars
decision to excuse himself from these
obligations and attack his own silenced
employees is alarming it sends an
unmistakable message to prosecutors and
agents if the president demands we will
throw you under the bus and Kravis is
not alone more than two thousand former
Department of Justice employees agree
they published a statement condemning
Barr and calling for his resignation
stating the Department's action is
extraordinarily rare if not
unprecedented if any of us or anyone
reading this statement who is not a
friend of the president were to lie to
federal investigators in the course of a
properly predicated counterintelligence
investigation and admit we did so under
oath we would be prosecuted for it they
go on to say that we thus unequivocally
support the decision of the career
prosecutor who withdrew from the Flynn
case just as we supported the
prosecutors who withdrew from the Stone
they are upholding the oath that we all
took and we call on their colleagues to
continue to follow their example like
Kravis these ex employees are also
extremely concerned about retaliation by
Barr and Trump quote President Trump
accused the career investigators and
prosecutors involved in the Flynn case
of treason and threatened that they
should pay a big price it is incumbent
upon the other branches of government to
protect from retaliation these public
servants and any others who are targeted
for seeking to uphold their oaths of
office and pursue justice Kravis is just
as skeptical of claims that the DOJ is
acting in good faith quote if the
department truly acted because of good
faith commitments to legal positions and
where is the evidence of those
commitments in other cases that do not
involve friends of the President where
are the narcotics cases in which the
department has filed a sentencing
memorandum overruling career prosecutors
where are the other false statements
cases dismissed after a guilty plea
speaking for myself if we want to have a
conversation about criminal justice
reform and curtailing some of the FBI's
power or their ability to use the broad
mandate of section 1001 so that we can
talk about a more fair justice system
I'm all for that
I and a whole bunch of other defense
lawyers would love to be able to remove
some of the power that the federal
government or other investigators have
when investigating people but this isn't
one of those cases this isn't a case of
reforming the underlying law it's a case
of special treatment doled out to one of
the president's closest advisors that is
the exact opposite of the rule of law
that's crony capitalism it's it's
corruption so many people who had no
frame of reference lashed out at some of
the tactics that the FBI used in this
particular case and were appalled but
the truth is the FBI has done similar
things in thousands if not hundreds of
thousands of other cases you want to
have a conversation about reforming some
of those actions of fine I'm all for it
but the Michael Flynn case is not the
venue for criminal justice reform it's
just simply special favors being doled
out to friends of the president the
opposite of the rule of law Flynn had
every advantage he was at the highest
echelon
government he had the best lawyers and
he spoke to the FBI voluntarily of his
own accord on advice of counsel he
wasn't railroaded he wasn't entrapped by
the government you want to talk about
criminal justice reform let's do it
this is not that case so let's talk
about what's going to happen next and
the judges role judge Sullivan is the
presiding judge and the government has
asked judge Sullivan in Flynn's case to
drop the prosecution entirely Sullivan
is not required to do so under rule 48 a
of the federal rules of Criminal
Procedure a government motion to dismiss
an indictment even after a guilty plea
requires what's called leave of court so
the judge gets to decide judge Sullivan
probably will grant the leave to dismiss
because there won't be an opposing party
both the government and Flynn are going
to argue in favor of dismissal but judge
Sullivan does have the discretion to
deny it and just go straight to
sentencing and it's significant that
Flynn pled guilty twice and the judge
Sullivan ruled Flynn's lies were
material to an investigation and that he
has already received sentencing
memorandum from both sides but we don't
really know what judge Sullivan will do
he's known as a mercurial judge and and
he will go his own way okay so fast
forward a couple of days and here's
where things really start to get crazy
in terms of the prosecution of Michael
Flynn and particularly judge Sullivan so
in reaction to this effectively
unprecedented motion by the Department
of Justice judge Sullivan started making
some moves the first thing that he did a
couple of days ago was that he issued a
minute order which is usually just a
short order that appears on pacer have a
huge document associated with it in
which he asked for third parties to
write what's called an amicus brief in
amicus brief is a brief filed by a third
party that has no stake in the case
itself it's an amicus brief filed by an
amicus curiae and this is very very
normal in an appeals context where
Appeals cases have far-reaching
implications they set precedent and so
it's not unusual for a third party to
want to weigh in when I have litigated
in front of the Federal Circuit's I
often have third parties file these
amicus briefs either in support of my
arguments or against my arguments
because they might be affected by it an
amicus brief is a very
usual thing in a trial court because
generally nobody cares except the
parties who were actually in trial but
court has inherent power to ask for
these amicus briefs and judge Sullivan
here has done so he apparently wants
additional opinions or briefs be filed
about this particular situation there
are multiple ways of spinning this but
the most likely situation is that the
judge is showing his displeasure with
the do JS position that because there's
no one arguing for the continued
prosecution of Michael Flynn he wants a
third perspective to be able to
understand countervailing issues and you
know given the unprecedented nature of
this motion to dismiss it's not crazy to
want someone else going to bat for the
prosecution of Michael Flynn typically
though the federal judge usually is
cedes to the request of the DOJ
prosecutors if the DOJ doesn't want to
move forward with of the prosecution of
an individual generally there's no
reason why the judge would not agree
with that position but obviously for
reasons that we have already discussed
this is not an usual situation and
nothing is really normal in the motion
to dismiss that the DOJ has filed now
after Judge Sullivan asked for these
amicus briefs that's when it really got
real he issued another order a few days
later in which Judge Sullivan has asked
for a magistrate judge to be appointed
to basically present an opposition to
the DOJ z-- motion the the order seeks
to appoint judge Gleason who is a former
federal prosecutor and former federal
judge and that judge is going to
basically make the arguments that the
DOJ is not making and moving forward
with Michael Flynn and on top of that
and here's where things really get
interesting magistrate judge Gleason is
going to decide if Michael Flynn has
committed criminal contempt by perjuring
himself so let's take a step back here
because this is this is pretty
unprecedented what is a magistrate well
a magistrate judge is sort of an ad hoc
hell
of the court so the the federal judges
are all appointed by the President of
the United States and they often deal
with situations that are either too
complex or too time-consuming to deal
with themselves or they want a neutral
third party view on a particular issue
so you would create what's called a
magistrate judge which is sort of an
ad-hoc position I've run into magistrate
judges a lot because often judges don't
wanna have to deal with discovery
literally millions of pages of documents
and so they hand that off to a
magistrate sometimes the magistrate is a
former federal judge or retired federal
judge and sometimes it is a lawyer who
wants to eventually become a judge so
they sort of get their training wheels
by becoming a magistrate in this
particular case judge Gleason is a
former federal judge retired but he's
also a former federal prosecutor and
here judge Gleason is sort of wearing
two hats on the one hand the first part
of the order requires judge Gleason to
be an advocate to oppose the DOJ z'
motion and the second half of the order
is effectively to be a neutral third
party and make an independent decision
as to whether Michael Flynn has
committed criminal contempt and perjured
himself now what's going to happen here
is absolutely anyone's guess and we
don't really know what to expect other
than the fact that this question of
whether Flynn committed criminal
contempt by perjury is separate from his
1001 guilty plea of lying to federal
officials so really it can only be in
connection with the representations that
Flynn has made to the court and of
course that is what criminal contempt is
for it's the inherent power of the judge
to punish people for shenanigans that
happen in front of them now of course
the DOJ dismissing a case after a guilty
plea is extraordinarily rare to the
point that I've never heard of it
happening but the judge appointing a
magistrate to oppose such a motion is
just uncharted territory in general
obviously some people are gonna argue
that this is yet more evidence of the
deep state railroading Michael Flynn and
some are gonna argue that this is simply
an independent judge standing up to a
clearly inferior motion by the
Department of Justice but as with the
request for third
briefing this really signals that Judge
Sullivan does not want to give in to the
Department of Justice he still might but
he's obviously going to put the DOJ
through the wringer before they get
there and in fact Sullivan has actually
done this before with the prosecution of
Ted Stevens so who knows what judge
Sullivan is ultimately going to do here
and not that the deep state Theory has
any merit but this may be in fact a bit
of a whipsaw that Judge Sullivan is
taking out a stick to try to get Michael
Flynn to do things the easy way instead
of the hard way judge Sullivan might be
showing that things can in fact get
worse that there's the possibility of
yet more jail time associated with
criminal contempt so it would behoove
him to simply move forward with the easy
thing of the guilty plea instead of
making a ruckus and potentially finding
more jail time so it might be a reason
to persuade Michael Flynn to to back
down from the shenanigans and and also
try to get the DOJ to back down things
can get worse before they get better for
them but I'd say that the DOJ has
already been embarrassed by this whole
episode and it seems like things are
gonna get worse before they get better
but ultimately here and this is great
advice for young lawyers old lawyers
pretty much anyone that may ever show up
in federal court do not mess with
federal judges they will make you regret
that so it's anyone's guess what may
happen next but this motion from the
Department of Justice is starting to
create a pattern from bil bars DOJ the
DOJ is emboldened it's suddenly
contradicting earlier prosecutorial
decisions without any rationale or
change circumstances and career DOJ
employees are resigning rather than sign
the pleadings only Tim Shea signed the
motion to dismiss and even then he did
it with the wrong bar number and given
the speculation about a presidential
pardon it really appears that this is a
backdoor pardoned by the Department of
Justice that instead of making President
Trump
take the fallout from actually pardoning
a sentenced and convicted Michael Flynn
they're not even going to get to that
stage by dismissing the investigation
entirely without even getting to
sentencing so it was like the plea never
happened at the end of the day Flynn
made phone calls to the Russian
ambassador
and then lied about them that's why he
was fired by the Trump administration
and apparently everyone from the NSA to
the GRU was listening to those phone
calls but the real travesty is how much
money that call probably cost Flynn he
could have saved so much money on a cell
phone bill with Singh mobile and you
know if you're gonna commit treason you
might as well do it as affordably as
possible and with teen Mobile's LTE
network your calls to Moscow will be
super clear ting Mobile is a different
kind of mobile provider with ting you
only pay for the actual data and
services that you use at the end of the
month and because you're paying for what
you actually use ting customers pay on
average just $23 per month for one
device and ting provides you with great
LTE coverage because it uses the
t-mobile Sprint and Verizon network so
now you get the benefit of all three of
these massive networks wherever you go
and with ting you can use almost any
cell phone including the newest iPhones
and pixel phones and you can use the
same phone number that you're using
right now there's no contract no overage
fees and no carrier tricks you just pay
a fair price for the talk text and data
that you use up every month and ting has
award-winning customer service because
they don't have any brick-and-mortar
stores not that you would go to a
brick-and-mortar store right now anyway
so they pour their resources into phone
support if you have an issue you can
give them a call you can send them a
text or you can go on social media or
Dischord and ting is great especially if
you're on Wi-Fi all the time which of
course most of us are our houses have
Wi-Fi because you'll end up paying way
way less than you do now because you
don't need to use a cellular network you
can just use the Wi-Fi network that
you're on anyway so you know some people
should pay $200 a month for unlimited
data if they're outside of the home but
if you're surrounded by Wi-Fi all day at
home or at work you might be paying
hundreds of dollars more per month
completely unnecessarily ting gives you
the option to pay for only what you use
so if you go to legal Eagle ENCOM you
can use your last bill to compare just
how much you would save and legal eagles
will get a twenty five dollar credit by
going to legal Eagle ENCOM and that
could cover your entire first month of
service and since there are no contracts
you can try it for a month no strings
attached again all you have to do is
click on the link in the description or
go to legal Eagle ENCOM get a $25
service credit for whatever you want and
of course clicking on the link in the
description really helps out this
channel and check out this other
playlist of all my other real law
reviews where I tackle
news of the day including quarantines
and craziness going on to the DOJ so
just click on this playlist and I'll see
you in court